la presidents loose on bootless
presidency organized as you know this
first political dialogue on respecting
the rule of law within the European
Union is he good thus we followed up on
the conclusions from the cans on the
respect of rule of law the rule of law
is one of the fundamental values one of
the cornerstones of the European Union
and a place and about the council plays
an important role in promoting and
consolidating a culture of which
encourages a respect of the rule of law
yellow the dialogue took place today in
accordance with the principles of
objectivity non-discrimination and equal
treatment between them all members
Legare go to war against the terrorist
army can only be waged if it is based on
the rule of law so given that backdrop
the the backdrop as well of the
migratory crisis we also looked at how
we could manage the migratory flows in
full respect of our fundamental values
including once again the rule of law in
order to protect our societies that we
have to prevent all forms of expression
and punish all forms of expression which
incite we contributed to preparation for
the European Council to be held on the
seventeenth and eighteenth of December
the agenda speaks for itself we will of
course be addressing the Paris attacks
the combat against terrorism that will
be a top priority the migratory crisis
as well of course and relations between
Russia and Ukraine and I think it will
also be an opportunity for us to hear
from the UK Prime Minister on their
proposals with a view to the UK
referendum the date for that and to have
a substantive debate on the subject
sabaku
you